Hello,
and welcome to today's episode of Clustered at
the Rawkode Academy.
My name is David Flanagan, although you may
know me across the internet as Rawkode.
Today we have a fantastic episode of Clustered,
but before we start that, there is a
little bit of housekeeping.
Please remember to like these videos, add comments,
share them, subscribe.
It just helps other people find this content
and we all have a lot more fun.
If you really wish, there are membership options
available on the academy to support the channel
and to get access to an InfluxDB Complete
Guide course, which is currently in flight. We
also have a very active discord community available
at Rawkode Chat,
where you can come and say hello, talk
all things Kubernetes, cloud native, Clustard, eBPF,
and just so much more cool stuff. It's
a great place. I look forward to meeting
you.
Alright.
Today is clustered. We are joined by two
members of the Discord community, our book club
organizers,
Eric and Carlos.
Hello, both of you. How are you both
doing today? Hello. Doing great. Alright. Let's start
with you, Eric. Do you wanna introduce yourself,
please?
Sure. So
I'm the guy who's here to learn because
I'm sure Carlos is going to decimate me
here, but not that it's competitive as we're
talking before the call.
Now I'm Eric Smalling. I am a former
DevOps consultant. I've been with VMware Docker VMware
twice, actually.
And I've been doing Docker containers
for, gosh, since, like, dot o six days.
Now I am a senior dev advocate at
Snyk. I've been there for almost a year
now, so focusing on container security and stuff
like that.
Thank you very much. Thanks for sharing. And
Carlos.
Hello. Hello. So glad to be here with
Eric. We meet every every Friday. We have
an open book club on Kubernetes, so anyone
wants to join our Discord.
So this is a fun thing because we
always
spend time on the book, and this time,
we're going to actually implement the stuff we're
learning. So
I
like I said, I worked in IBM for
the last about twenty years.
Last things around cloud native, I implemented something
called IBM Cloud Functions,
serverless. And then the last four years, I've
been doing,
cloud architecture with Kubernetes OpenShift most likely,
and, yeah, helping customers get into production with,
cloud and Kubernetes.
And I'm also a a technical lead for
the Knative, so I do a lot of
open source.
Alright. Thank you very much.
We have a question from Noel in the
chat. Is Carlos wearing a clustered shirt?
Yes. I mean,
David is trying to hire me, so I
feel like one over one.
Alright. Awesome. So we're about to kick off
first. It's going to be Carlos and I
working on
Eric's cluster. Yep. I have Eric's cluster available.
So before we do that, I just wanna
thank Teleport. They've been sponsoring Clustered recently. I
really appreciate all their support. We've been using
their product since, like, the first episode. I
love it. You're gonna see us using it
today. It's a wonderful tool. So thank you
to Teleport.
Alright. Eric, Chris is where you get to
sit back, relax, pop a beer, have some
laughs, taunt us in the chat, whatever you
wish. Carlos, I'm gonna pause our timer. That's
a bit harsh. I'll start that when we
go. We have forty minutes. Our mission
is to upgrade our cluster deployment on the
server to v two and browse to the
application.
I'm going to on Teleport, pop open our
root session on the control plane one. If
you could do me a favor and join
this session and just type an echo hello,
anything to let me know that you are
there, and we will get underway.
And my mic's still working. Right? It is
still working. We can hear you.
See if that's me. Perfect. Cool. Alright.
So I will start the timer now, Carla.
Feel free to get our KubeConfig set up,
and let's check for a control plan.
Cool. So
let's do export.
KubeConfig.
It should be in a to c Kubernetes.
Should be no
config. Right?
Perfect. My alias
k equals kubectl.
Good call.
I'm a fan of completion.
I cannot live without completion.
So
completion, I can never remember
the solution,
but it's always in the help.
So that
and then I'm a fan of completing
on
pay. Right? So that's that's the problem. So
our graph
is
stuff showing up on your site? It is.
Yeah.
Okay. Just, like, be I'm being anal about
my terminal and my Kubernetes stuff. I don't
have all my tools here, so I'll I'll
see what I can do. To honest, I
don't know how to set up the completion
on the key alias, so that was nice.
I like that.
I I think I did. Right? We're about
to find out. Yeah. So
get get
yep. Namespaces,
network policies, and notes. So do we have
notes?
Oh. So nice. So Eric left me
Control
Yeah. Control play. Right? So API.
I I prepare I I prepare all week
for fixing the API server, so now I
don't know what to do.
So let's see. We have pods. Right?
Yeah. We have Interesting restarts going on there.
Restart I mean, things are running, but they've
been they've been flip tapping.
Yeah.
And the one that we're looking for is
cluster.
Right? So we are
see how
is our deployment doing.
Look at the format of those pod names.
Those do not look like a replica set
to close to me.
Right?
The you mean the these two guys? Yeah.
Clustered, and then there's a replica set ID,
and then a pod ID, and then a
suffix?
Yeah. So it's like they're
static bugs. Sets or something maybe or static.
Yeah. Maybe. Static bugs.
Where are they coming from? So let's check
who the owner is. Right? So we do
get bug.
Let's look at one of them, worker one.
That's o yaml.
And this guy oh, scrolling is working.
And we have
who created this thing? Owner reference. Right? Yeah.
The owner reference. Was created by
the node.
How come this thing is created by the
node?
So this should be a a static pod.
Let me check the the deployment still here.
Yeah. Let's take it Right. Scale down. Let's
see if the the replica was scaled down.
Let's see how many
replicas we have.
Spec.
Where's the replicas?
Replicas?
Yeah. They're set to zero.
You see it? I see it. In fact,
if we if we use less,
we can page it together. That might be
a bit easier. But yeah. It's We have
hours?
Ah, here it is.
Right.
But we have we have fake bugs. We
can try to delete them, I I guess
in the will come back.
Right?
I do
unless we want to
see if we have endpoints in this team.
I I don't know if they're actually harming
us yet. I mean, we could just Yeah.
Scale back. They could be running. Right? Yeah.
So maybe we can do
they're they're there. K. Get service
and cluster it on 3,000. Right? So we
do local host
3,000. You have it configured for
Yep. 30,000
that is running on. Yep.
Not responding.
Interesting.
Okay.
So
network policy, just in case.
We don't have network policies. K get
Cilium.
Yeah. CMP and c c c m p,
I think. C CMP?
CMP and C CMP. Yeah.
C c And CMP is so as cluster
network policies and then cluster wide network policies.
I see it now. Selium
cluster network policy. Selium
what's the other one? Network policies.
Yep.
Okay.
So do you want to describe the service?
Yeah. We can describe the service.
Yeah. So, yeah, port. It's eighty eighty, three
thousand. It looks fine. I'm getting endpoints. So
let me describe the pods.
I did I think I already did describe
the pods, right, underwear.
Happy,
I think.
No events.
Do you see it?
Let me see.
He's being sneaky.
The image. The
image.
This guy. Eric? So it's a different image.
Welcome.
I kinda wanna try to present to it.
See
we have logs for this for this. It
is not our image anyway. Right? So we
don't Yeah. I'm hoping he's left as a
wee
a wee message.
No. I don't think it's gonna resolve. You
wanna see the logs? Yeah. Let's do the
logs.
It's just asking that we scale up the
cluster deployment. No. We've not done that yet.
We're still exploring the the rogue image.
Yeah. I will tell you those pods are
hosting something.
Are hosting something? They are. They're there.
Alright. So if we fix the ingress to
the cluster, we should be able to see
what the sum is. Do you want to
open it in the ingress? Yeah. It's not
working. We're getting an internal server error. So
if there's some network policy or IP tables
blocking access to the node port?
Yeah. This looks like just NGINX image, I
guess.
We can do a k exec inside the
Yeah. Cluster.
Let's see if what we have inside.
Oh,
right.
Local host
eighty eighty.
Connection refused.
There. Get the port run. So
I'm thinking, like, maybe
we don't care about this bot. Let's delete
them and get yours running. Oh, but I
wanna see what your left is.
Oh, okay.
Let's see what's running on this thing.
Ah, interesting.
What?
He's running get TTY.
What sneaky thing have you been doing?
So I think this is run as a
static pod because it's properly run-in as privilege,
and he's trying to pipe something through from
the horse,
like a TTY console.
But it's not serving a web server. Right,
Eric?
Yeah. I think I saw a message that
logs. Since I started it. Yes. There is
an NGINX server running in there.
There was.
Gonna say crashed.
There's no guarantees what I did was stable.
And look at the pet numbers as well,
actually. This this is definitely a privileged container.
Right? Oh, yeah.
Okay. So we are inside.
What's PID? So it's just running as a
privileged container. Oh, we we are not inside
the container,
are we?
Think so. Yeah. No? No. We are in
a host. Oh, no. No. No. I think
I was inside for a second.
Right. Right. Right. Okay. No. No. I know.
I'm not Oh, you forgot dash IT.
Yeah. Right
now we are. Local host.
I don't have colors in my terminal. Tell
me where I am. Alright. We have HTML.
Okay. Right?
And you said that maybe the ingress is
broken? Yeah. I think those IP tables or
something is blocking the node port access because
we can't do a curl local host 30,000.
But let's confirm. Right? I mean, let me
grab the
worker one IP address,
and I'll just browse to it at my
browser.
You can do a port forward. Right?
There
we go.
Oh, you got it? Yeah.
So the service the NodePort service isn't working,
but if I browse the Node IP
to Zambokov. This
some This may be too old for most
people on the call. Welcome.
This is some Are you familiar with Zambokov?
Welcome to Zombokam.
I'll leave that for a minute. You can
do it. Can First way to Zombokam.
Alright. I've had enough So what so maybe
Rawkode's Rawkode's going with the ingress? The ingress
cannot talk to
the thing?
So Teleport runs on the control plane, and
it would appear the control plane can't hit
the node port on one of the workers.
I I don't know if we need
yeah. We will need to worry about it,
but we've seen what this You
can access it through
okay.
Yeah. I think we can just get rid
of those static pods now. I think Alex
had his his fun with ZomboCom and
Okay. That was meant for later. I didn't
think you'd solve that one first.
Okay. Let's get rid of static pods, so
then we'll we'll do something.
We'll work it through. How do we get
to the other worker nodes? Yeah. I'll open
a session on the worker nodes now, and
you can just join a session. So
we got worker one now available for you.
Let me see.
Maybe.
I need to refresh on my side?
No. It's actually failing to get a connection.
Hey.
One rule, Eric. There's one rule. I didn't
break that rule
as of Friday afternoon or sun Saturday, whenever
it was. I Alright. I see now.
It didn't load for me. I'm trying worker
to oh.
I saw a session on worker one.
Oh, but it's not getting a prompt. Yeah.
K. That's not intended.
Can you SSH from somewhere? I can. Yes.
The working one? Yeah. We could do it
old school.
I've got a terminal
going in.
We just want to remove the static manifest.
Right? So I'll just do that and then
Yeah.
Alright. The static manifest is gone from worker
one, and I'll do worker two.
I see.
David knows that at one point, I did
break rule number one, and he had to
reset my cluster.
Oh, really? Yeah. That that that man you
wanted to be? That that how much you
you hate me, I guess.
No. It was it was my mistake. It
was not a
it was not intentional.
Okay. Now we get pods. Looks normal. So
let's fix our scaled down deployment,
I guess. So
let's do
k scale deployment.
We're gonna cluster.
That's dash replicas equals how many replicas you
want? One?
Yeah. One's fine.
But
it's creating.
It's creating. Let's see.
Wow. It's taking a long time. So
the Rust Rust code must be big. Yep.
Oh, we got an error.
Yeah. Let's see.
I cannot get to
It is a networking bug.
There we go. Failed.
So the DNS resolved.
DNS.
Did it?
Oh, no. Wait. So DNS request is DNS.
Image rank. Yeah. Look up g c g
h c r I o on why is
it going out of my
that could be one of the node IPs
14775,
actually. Okay. So Failed to resolve reference.
Failed to resolve reference.
Failed to request.
Oh, the head. Right? So I failed the
LTCP.
I think it's DNS.
Yeah. I'm getting back an IP address.
But I think that's the cost the node
IP.
Oh, yeah. This is 53. So this is,
like, the DNS server. Yeah. I think this
is our control plane or one of our
working node IP addresses, which I can confirm.
To wait.
So
the way DNS works is
oh, I cannot type any longer.
We're
using core DNS?
We are. Yeah. And then core DNS uses
our resolve.
ETC
resolve.
Does that look correct?
So this is
Where how do I resolve Google? How do
I resolve GCR.io?
I think I need a a a a.
So the 14775
is the correct prefix for this, that what
I would expect. But those last two octets
are wrong from what I can tell.
But you don't have a DNS server running
on these
folks? Not unless EquinixMetel are providing DNS, which
I don't think is normally the case.
Right? Because the other place would be
bar
lib
to lead
it. Right?
Let's just because the first two octets are
right, I'm inclined to think
they're okay. I think we just need to
fix the networking maybe.
Right. So
are you saying that this is not DNS?
Would I have to resolve the DNS?
Let's let's check.
Bind.
Now I need to do the weird 50
variations of DNS and binder tools. There we
go.
DNS Tools. Oh, there we go. Okay. Yeah.
How are you going to install something? We
cannot the DNS is not working. Right?
So let's Yeah. Okay. So
This DNS is not working on this machine,
so let's configure it with
Google's DNS?
Yeah.
We can. Although, we ping eight dot eight
dot eight dot eight? Let's check if it's
the full stack or if it has DNS.
I don't know if this thing will work.
Okay. Yeah. Okay. So let's just swap out
the resolve then.
So do we do the system d or
the ETC? I'm not remember.
We can just modify the ETC resolve. I
don't I don't think we need to change
this system d one. And we can just
go with, yeah, e.e.e.
Server. So try this
at first. Right?
Correct.
And then we should be able to
in Google.
That might not be the one
unless
we have IP tables. It went to IP
tables.
Show
dump. Dash l, capital l.
That's it.
Any drops?
None. I don't expect this. Oh, wait. There.
It's fine. Right?
Yeah. Drop all UDP traffic.
Is that a problem? That is a problem.
Yeah. Yeah. That's a problem.
So we need to
flush that rule.
I mean, we could just flush them all
and restart
the With the firewall?
We could just do IP tables flush,
and then we should be able to
there we go. Yeah.
That it? That's DNS?
Well, I mean, we also have flushed every
Selium role, but Selium will catch up eventually.
Yeah. So let's see let's see the pod.
Right? And let's
I'm impatient. So let's delete the plot.
Try again.
You left hints in this?
No.
I'm your verbal your homework?
Started say verbally.
You haven't spoke since we started. Yes. I
did. Okay.
And what's going on in the chat? Anybody
making fun?
Yeah. We have Noel.
Hi, Noel. Khalid. Walid.
What's the all the book club is here.
I don't know. People, I think, want to
skip homework for Friday.
Alright.
So we're still getting
filled. Oh, because that's on the worker nodes.
So I bet that rule's that rule's been
replicated, hasn't it?
I'll try the session.
Alright. Yeah. So IP tables dash l for
a p two p.
Actually,
I don't think there's a check over there.
He he replicated the rules on all the
machines.
Oh, okay. Just to frustrate it. Yeah.
So the, yeah, the DNS
so the I guess the DNS was correct.
Was just IP tables.
But if it was DNS,
was the the work the pods get the
DNS from from CD and CD from the
control plane. So it's easy to resolve on
the workers will not do anything. Okay. I
So you fixed the other two? Yeah. I
have. I think if we delete that pod
and try again, maybe we'll we'll get back
in.
Let's try again.
Okay.
Delete.
Delete
bug.
Let's do it.
I think that bugs h w.
Oh, it's running. Wee.
Alright. So we have Refresh our
I check if we have endpoints.
Yep. We've got the watch.
Oh, cool.
So now we can update? We can try.
Appointment.
Customer led.
Change to v
I don't know if you explained the rules
for the audience if somebody's new. So idea
is to get v one working and then
upgrade to v two. Let's do
clear.
If you're not a fan of the show,
you should be.
But
w terminating
terminating.
Let's see.
I think running.
Not yet. But
sometimes it takes 15,000
refreshes before I get my dance.
Haven't worked out why.
What's going on? Maybe it's already running. You
wanna confirm the image? Oh, yeah. It's it's
running already.
So let's
let's see.
Yeah. We got events.
Yeah. Are we done? Yep. There we go.
That's it?
There was a second hack that apparently didn't
didn't work.
What was the hack? Supposed to be able
to do it after just clearing the IP
tables.
Interesting. Can you do a a a
I don't wanna give it away, but okay.
Can you do a t c We're done.
I'm curious about something on my cluster because,
basically, the DNS was just bonus. That wasn't
really what I was aiming for there. I
was trying to destroy
the VXLAN communications
Yeah. And
which I did,
which is why
even without DNS, you weren't gonna be weren't
gonna be able to get that thing connectable.
However,
there's a second stage to it that apparently
didn't work
long term. I'm not sure why.
I also had a a a traffic control
command in there that if you do a
t c space
q d I s c space show.
Q what? D I s c. I s
c, like disk,
space show.
I wonder if this got cleared out.
With the IP tables
flushed? There should be a so there should
be something that's basically throwing away a %
of all traffic on the Cilium VX LAN
on all nodes.
And it looks like it got cleared out.
So something I I didn't count on something
maintaining
traffic control behind my back. Yeah. You'll probably
find with because if we take a look
at the custom namespace, those silly and pause
were rotating
a fair bit, and I wonder if maybe
the
oh, I don't know. I'm guessing. What about
persistent on the worker nodes? Did they reboot
it?
How how do you persist that traffic control
configuration
when the server I thought it auto persisted.
I'm I'm not enough of an expert on
it. This was a bonus that somebody I
was talking to said, hey. You could do
this too. And then well, that way they
wouldn't see it in the IP tables.
I thought, oh, that's a good idea. But
Yeah. I don't see it on the workers
either, so not sure what happened there. I
I
so you went to the extra you went
to the extra mile to ask someone how
to be meaner with this this app. Right?
Right. I was saying to try. Thank you
for not trying. Sorry.
Like I was saying, this was
this was an
exercise in trying to
David and Goliath, except I have no rocks.
Let's put it that way.
You are the much more experienced here. So
this should be interesting when we flip the
tables. Alright. Let's do it then. Okay. Let's
drop the session. No. That would be boring.
Thanks.
Alright. Well done,
Carlos.
Eric,
your turn. So
now I go to hold on a second.
Let me get over to the right window.
Alright. I have got Carlos' cluster. I have
opened a root session. Just let me know
when you are there.
Where
is the sessions?
I see the chat. I think the people
Just ignore Noel. Noel's being mean.
Noel,
I was afraid of a eBPF hack on
the system d that are for not that
I watch every episode this week, but
There we go.
Joining session. Mobile eBPF.
Alright.
Let's see. You see me? I can see
you. Alright. I will start the timer. You
set up your config.
Check the
the API server, and let's see what happens.
Let's see if we have we don't have
it yet.
I
think teleport have fixed the scroll. That's awesome.
Said in the chat saying, what are the
odds that Carlos's break involves k native?
Do you have any admission controllers run with
k native, Carlos?
It involves k native in some way. Yes.
It involves k native, actually.
Oh, I shouldn't say anything.
Alright. Well, we we have an API server.
We don't have two worker nodes.
Cluster, it looks like it's
not happy. Yeah. It's a little bit broken.
And yeah. Alright. K. Postgres is scaled down,
but it looks good too.
And what do you wanna start with then,
Eric?
Hold on. Let me rearrange so I can
see both your screen and mine. Yeah. Take
a look.
I'm Well, there's no point. Sorry.
Go ahead.
I thought you were setting some stuff up
on your screen. Was gonna say I was
just gonna describe an order and see if
we could see the not ready states, but
I'll Go go
ahead and do that. Alright. So
I'll paper through left so we share scroll.
Yeah.
Network unavailable false.
Node status unknown.
I think the kubelet's just not running.
Yeah.
I think our first mission is to jump
onto the worker one. So
I popped a session on there. Let's check
the status of the kubelet.
K.
I'm jumping on that session.
Okay. There.
I think it did.
Hopefully,
he just stopped it.
Scroll broke.
There we go.
You see anything?
I don't see any. I think he literally
just did a system control stop kubelet.
I think we should just start it and
see what happens. Yeah.
It's up and running.
Yeah. It looks good.
Let's see if we can get some node
status.
Yeah.
It's now ready. So I I'll start it
on worker two.
Okay.
And then we'll go back to the control
plane.
Oops. Sorry. Oh, I'm sorry. Go ahead. I
was just trying to get notes to confirm
they were both ready.
Go for it.
Alright.
What's next?
So the pods are gonna count. It's pending
now.
Service up it is. So
The auto complete thing like him, I'm not
fancy.
Yeah. I think I can remember that command.
So Carlos did a complete,
like, create
cube control and then he copied this and
changed second cube control to k.
That's now my favorite type of all time.
So Nice.
Did we load the completion at the start?
Say that again? Did we load completion? Yeah.
We did. Okay. Yeah. We're good. Take it
away.
Are you guys trying to see the bot?
It was still pending, so I was wanting
to see what's going on. If
you watched the search magic on Cloud Native
TV this afternoon, I discussed the pending state
on a pod.
No. I did not.
Why is our image from Quay? Is that
normal? No.
That's cheeky.
Also, did not rename my username from Rawkode
to
Carlos Santana.
Then you can delete them, the parts, and
get them with Russell's giving me a trouble
for blindly starting the Kubelet service without checking
the definition.
Whoops.
And then Noel wants YouTube to have GIF
support.
I do not need trolled with GIFs too.
So the the hint you can look at
the hints,
but to retry, just delete the pods and
then We don't need no hints, Carlos.
We got this.
Delete the pods
so you don't lose time on the other
stuff. That would make sense. To deploy the
the image looks fine. So
Yeah. Delete them. See what happens.
They come back.
You're a little too
was not a little bit If I if
I broke it correctly now.
It should be
okay. Three seconds.
Now you can describe it. Yeah. Describe that.
Pending is never good.
Yeah. More useful message.
Oh, the image came back.
So I think we need to check for
a mutating admission controller.
Nope. But
pipe.
Yeah. Mutation
web configurations,
I believe, is the name.
Help me out. Yep.
Okay.
So we don't have one of those.
Do you mind if I let's describe the
replica set.
Well, you checked the deployment. The the deployment
had the correct image. So let's check the
replica set and see if that's got the
right image. I wanna know if it's happening
at the pod level or the rep set
level.
I'm now I'm curious why you're not getting
messages.
Oh, I see. I see.
What I broke. I forgot that I broke
something else.
Check check the hints if you want. They're
funny. I don't know.
Yeah. Check the hints with three minutes left.
Okay.
No. Don't look at the hints. No. This
is this is a good one. Like yeah.
Don't don't look at the hints. Don't look
at the hints? Okay.
Why don't we Yeah. The white spot what's
happening? This spot is not being what?
What should be what? Yeah. Yep. You found
it. Our replica sets.
Okay. So the replica set is actually correct.
Yeah. Our pod was created. So
interesting. What is the what is the process
of
creating a pod?
The bug gets created? And then I'll then
customer must be care again.
What's running in our cluster? Can we do
a get pods all?
Yeah. There might be something sick.
Ambassador.
Everything.
Yeah. I'm gonna assume he swapped out the
images on the controller manager.
Let's describe the controller manager.
Come on. Autocomplete.
Helps to give it pod.
I'm looking at your scroll.
The image is is good, annoyingly.
So it's a nice effect.
Delete the pod. The pod comes back.
The image has changed.
So we're gonna have to check the image
on the API server now. Should we go
to the static pod directory and take a
relook?
The worker on the oh, sorry. Which one?
On the control plane. Yeah. It's a Kubernetes
manifest.
Let's see what is changed in here.
Oh, beta dog 20.
Yeah. We'll need to check the API server
too.
The image looks good.
Assuming this is the right static pod directory,
which you could also have changed.
That's true. Let's check the API server before
we go down another rabbit hole.
Image is good. Okay.
Could be a container D trick.
Like what?
Like he's
wait a second.
Yeah. Did you I I thought you you
described clustered. Right? And it was
I was wanting to see if he changed
the image load policy and if it's only
loading from cached.
Oops. I'm
failing.
Yeah. Let's let's grab that for image and
see what we get back.
Full policy always.
I like I like it.
So
let's think what's just see, it's really weird
because the API server is giving us back
the image, is
car loss. They're infuriating.
Hot.
Check that.
Noelle, we did check for mutating webhooks.
That is sneaky, Carlos, whatever you've done here.
So the replica set is created with the
right image. The pod is then being created
with one. I think the only way I
know how to do that would be for
him to swap out
API server
or to a mutating admission control. Now he
could be hiding the mutating admission control from
us. Right? Like Yeah.
But
I'm I'm
it's I will be over my head on
that then. How would you do that?
Rename it rename it something that looks innocuous?
It's it's simpler than that.
Look at the hint. Check. Oh, yeah. Check
the hints. I we checked the hints. I
I think Unless but don't look at all
of them. Just them in order so you
see only the beginning.
Alright. So we fixed that one.
Yep. Fixed.
Yeah. You let it down.
Is that important?
Yeah. That's fixed already. Alright. Okay. Yeah. I
wasn't sure what there's a play on words
for Kubelet, I believe.
Yeah. This is I think you're using a
static pod. Alright. Okay.
So read read the sentence.
You think in action this poor static pod.
So you can hide
resource. We can hide the the mutate and
admission controller configuration.
Missing in action, this poor static pod.
No DNS, but then that's not
scheduler,
tool manager, API server, etcd.
So what's
Is that the right hand for this problem,
Carlos?
Yes. Yes. Okay.
Missing an action. That's pure static. I'm going
to check. So there's there needs to be
a a list of yep.
He did change the static directory.
You even said that, and we didn't follow-up
on it. That's
So I bet he has swapped our controller
manager and API server. Yeah.
Controller manager is maybe alright. I didn't search
a bunch.
And API server alright. We're gonna have to
go through the options then.
And so with the API server, he could
have configured a static admission controller,
which he's not.
I have no idea what I'm looking for.
I'm just dim scrolling at the moment.
Oh, there's no scheduler here.
That's true. That is accurate,
which makes sense. That's why it's that's why
it's pending because it has it doesn't know
what node to put it on.
But the image has also changed in the
pod.
Right?
Yeah. Scheduler wouldn't do that.
I don't think.
Okay. Let's bring back the scheduler.
That's hiding the fact that yeah. It would
not normally would say image pull problem or
something
unless he's got it. No. He probably has
an image on Quay. Never mind.
Yeah. I'm gonna trust that the manifests in
here are actually okay. I think saying enable
the hack.
Okay. We have a scheduler now.
Let's just kill those puppets.
Yeah. Let's kill the pot so we don't
lose time.
That's my sister in the in the chanting,
Russell.
Delete the pass so you don't lose time
on the other stuff.
Let's take a look at
why are we in Kubernetes with a c?
Did we did you delete it?
No. Did you describe it?
Describe it to see if you have events.
Oh, he just tinted the notes.
You happy for us to delete the tents?
Okay. So we have a container creating, but
I'm still really worried about that image on
the pod.
I don't know how he's achieved that yet.
You're seeing things.
The deployment should have the right image.
The deployment did. The replica set that the
pod didn't.
I don't know how you did that. Yeah.
So now you're surprised.
Check the deployment. I think the deployment was
correct.
Oh, correct. So is
it running?
We have blank blank, but They are running.
Would you like me to browse to your
application?
If
the if the database is not working, I
don't think it will work.
Right? I tested your image. Yeah. I'm trying
to think you've been writing some Rust, Carlos.
I yeah.
I like Rust.
Do we have a
database yet? No. Crashed.
Alright.
Oh,
crash? I didn't do that. Check the database.
K.
Yeah. We're getting an internal server at our
our databases, and I crashed it back up.
Oh, no. It's restarting.
Oh,
I need to do that, I think.
Are you sure?
It's flapping.
Do you edit my stateful set?
I didn't do anything with the database.
Well, you should you should get if you
you don't have a database, you should get
your angry man. Right? Yeah. So we still
have a networking problem.
Yeah. So that one, I did.
Let's see.
Alright. Let's work at the networking problem, Eric.
Okay.
I I was looking at documents for a
second while you apparently the the c the
Kubernetes with the c, is that his alternative
directory, I guess?
Correct. So I copied the scheduler and and
trusted that the other manifests were okay.
More fun hints.
We want to look at the hints.
No. I think we got enough things threads
to put on right now. I'm curious about
the networking. I wanna be able to fix
the ingress onto the cluster.
And I also wanna check the container d
configuration
for using
the matter alias.
Perfect. No worries.
If the pod is coming up and then
crashing, and is it not logging anything?
Any reason?
No. I'm saying the first time we see
prod is crashing like that, I don't know.
But it might be some related to some
builder hacks.
Alright. Let's do curl
h p.
Let's check our node port.
Broken.
I'm gonna do that on a worker node
as well.
Broken.
No. Fine. Okay.
That's expected.
So the control plane can't reach the worker
nodes.
When do you wanna check first?
I mean, the first thing, just like you
did for mine, let us look at see
if there's any net policies. Oh, yeah. Oh,
look at app tables, know, I mean, obviously.
Defaults,
all pods.
I don't think that's allowing. I think that's
a denial. Yeah.
That's that's saying the opposite of what it
is.
Yeah.
Since we checked these on your cluster, we'll
check them here.
Alright. Good.
So we'll try the curl again.
Okay. We fixed that.
I like that you both used a network
policy.
I
can't believe that that would be that's not
the database issue, though. I have Wouldn't I?
I mean, the database doesn't rely on
anything.
No.
It's the self bootstrapping Is
it does it have a volume that it's
mounting that it can't?
No.
Is it all it's all self contained? Yeah.
Let's see what happens after
a few seconds.
No. Press restart.
Are you sure you didn't break this?
Yeah. I think so. I I think I
broke it
without Is the liveness probe?
Yeah. Check.
I mean, we don't need wherever you're going,
we don't need probes.
Check the image.
Just yeah. I want to help out. Check
the image of that database
in the pod.
Did I delete too much? No. It's okay.
I'm just removing them.
Okay. Running.
Okay. So there's maybe another networking thing then.
Is there anything that your app logs
that would be more sorry.
Go ahead. Check the images on that database
on the pod.
Oh, if you turn a weird thing with
both of them, you cheeky monkey. Yeah. I
wanted to break one, but I think I
broke two.
Yep.
I hate you so much.
I unintentionally
broke the
the database.
Alright. So we need to we need to
solve this. Right? Like, the deployment, the rep,
like I said, have the correct image. How
is he solving gonna be a great hack.
It's going to be me dancing, but it
didn't work anyway.
Alright.
I'm gonna because I had a hunch that
he's used the container deconfig,
so
and he is not. Alright.
I'm gonna be honest. I don't know how
he's done that without mutating the machine controller.
And all the control plane components seem normal.
I'm starting to think it could just have
modified the DNS to resolve the query, but
I don't know why
It wouldn't say this. It wouldn't update it
in the pod. Yeah. It would just be
the one time use a different image.
You're right.
That's a really cool trick, Carlos. I hate
you.
I have to hit me.
But how I said it wasn't competitive, it's
competitive now. Alright? That's it. Yeah.
I'm
thinking we'd use the hints,
Eric. I'm I'm at a loss, mate.
Use the what? I'm thinking we look at
the hints.
Yeah. They're in order. Yeah. I just
what hint what's what hint are we on?
What well, Dave said that he was going
to wait three minutes.
Like, when what's left to secret hint? It
doesn't want to wait. Let's take a look
at three or four. I can't remember which.
Cannot Cannot or node. It may be painted.
Alright. We will do that. We will do
that.
Yep. We got that. Oh,
please allow all do not deny policy. Yeah.
You got that one.
That was that was the thing that you
were you were going to see, but you
didn't see. So that was that was the
swap of the image.
It was going to be me dancing, but
So
So the next the next hint to
oh, no. Yeah. This is the hint.
I'm sorry. Yeah. Is there mean, do we
wanna go to six? Or
I wanna check some more manifest. That's that's
half of the hint in this one and
the next one have the other half.
So, yeah, this this hint. This problem is
split in two.
So what does this sentence says? Read it
carefully, the hint.
The mutant's changed the music. You're hunting at
an admission controller.
I just don't know
Music.
How you're gonna end.
I see someone.
The mutants
change the music.
I wonder if you could just inject it
directly
into the EDC d.
Yeah. That that
And
My kidney function, I I did a bug.
So I
I I changed too much. I changed both
the image and the I changed the the
app and the database. I wanted only to
change the app. But, anyway
So,
I mean, that's not API server seems
All right. I was checking PS because I
was curious. In fact,
I said I would start doing this in
future. Was looking to see what random stuff
you've added to my system.
Nothing.
But I thought there was maybe a second
API server running on the machine, and we
were speaking to the wrong one.
Like,
like, API server in my client function in
the cloud?
No.
That's not it.
I mean, we could we could add a
blanket IP table rules to block all external
traffic on six four four three and see
if it helps.
Although, who knows what port he's running on?
I'm not I'm not that smart.
I don't know much about IP tables.
Okay. So this is our API server. We
got advertise,
alert privilege, authorization.
We got our node restriction admission controller, which
is all good.
We've got
There's
nothing wrong with this API server from what
I can see.
Yeah. This image appears to be
alright.
I mean, we could always describe it in
the pod, but I think I did that
and I think it was okay.
I'm
being really
silly, aren't I?
Hold on.
What?
What if he pulled the image and changed
the pill policy?
This this isn't necessarily
my API server.
Case9Case7,
emoji. Oh, you gotta put this namespace first.
Correct.
There's two APIs.
So It's gonna fix it. Right, Carlos? It's
gonna fix it.
What did you change?
I set the image pool policy on the
API server to always.
Because you want what I I think you
see the the machine with a fake image,
a fake API server.
API server is not in charge of changing
those.
Well,
I could do it. The controller manager. Okay.
So, yeah, you're telling me I just need
to update them all. Alright. Got you.
Don't trust anything.
No.
Oh,
I don't think I touched any of these
these folks.
Well, that makes me very disappointed.
No. Those those images are are legit.
And they're coming from the right place. Right?
So oh, but you think I put them
there and cache them? Uh-huh. Yeah. Otherwise
And you're you're telling me that's not what
you did? Nah. Too boring.
Alright. What happened are we on, Eric? We're
too we're too too clever. I'm not that
good. Six. Oh,
hints. I want to see the hints. It's
patient.
Yeah.
Oh, you mother.
That's twice I've been burned by that.
If it was.
Want to explain to people watching what you're
doing to you?
It's Eric driving? What's what's Eric No. That's
that's has. You should be fixing this, Eric.
So can you explain it for folks? I
think people are a little bit lost. Yeah.
Let me run through that. So if we
run alias
grab to cube control,
he's running a script called HVWC.
The script called HVWC
is grabbing for anything where the resource is
mutating and returning no resources found.
That's
almost as evil as Duffy's fake
SSH
container.
You want the you see the YAML the
YAML of it?
I want
what I want to do is fix Postgres
and see you then.
So
what I'm going to do is yeah. We'll
get the YAML.
It's for fun
because you can see the hack.
When we're done, remind me to tell you
what I didn't do in mine that I
could've that was related.
Okay.
So you've got this running on
app codeengine.appdomain.cloud.
Is that some IBM service?
Yes. K native as a service. Nice.
Just shoot
it.
Okay. So that's now gone,
but I'm gonna describe the pod.
If if you go to Kubernetes
seek seek app machinery, you will see some
chat in there. I was trying to hide
it in a different way, but I couldn't.
With a validation webhook, hide the mutation webhook,
but I could.
Okay.
So I did it this way with alias.
Right?
Where's my pod?
Did we lose our scheduler? No. Did we
lose our controller manager?
Check the system
Get parts again. I think it's just take
a second.
Yeah. I've not got controller manager.
What's the problem?
I don't know. It doesn't seem to like
that change.
Alright. It's back now. So we should get
our pod.
And I think the first thing we're gonna
do is edit deployment
clustered.
Queta I o slash
your username
clustered.
I mean, we all wanna see it. Oh,
you wanna see it? Oh, you want to
see it? Okay. Yeah. I think you you
have a, indentation problem.
So is the database running now?
Yes.
Okay.
Oh, no. We need to delete the database
because I removed all the probes.
So that's still your image.
Yeah. The chat or else then, the one
I see you dance. Okay. Oh, okay. Okay.
I don't dance that well.
So I was gonna do the same thing
and wrap IP tables to hide the drop,
But
Duffy and I were talking because he's my
network go to, and he's like, oh, that
would be mean.
Nice.
Well played.
Alright. Let's let's finish this.
I forgot what I'm doing. Alright.
Set to v two Yeah. We gotta change
it back to yours.
I'm assuming it's just gonna work. Right?
I would hope so. I I said that
I was mean by this time, so I
said, like, it's gonna be day.
There's some there's no more hints. Right? I
think you found the hints. You can check
the hints. There's something else.
And that should be
I guess it's cached.
Even though you have it set it up
to there you go.
Ask the dancer people like, not me.
Very nice, Carlos.
I can't believe we got burned by an
alias.
You don't run alias the first time you
went to set up Yubectl?
No. I'm too trusting,
which I should look at right now.
I want I want the chance, oh, they
might just run it.
So that's the reason
auto completion didn't work because I had kubectl
two and alias.
So you you folks set up auto completion
correctly, but it wasn't working because of the
alias.
Damn it.
Alright. Well played.
Two fun clusters.
We got there.
Cool. It was fun. I'm gonna let you
I'm
I'm I'm raging about that, I guess. I've
gotta say. Like, I'm gonna have to write
a new list of rules now.
Alright. It's the love for the episode in
the chat. This episode was awesome.
Yeah. Was good fun. It was nice to
do this.
Please update the official v two image with
the Carlos dance. No.
No.
I think we will need to find a
way for that to survive somehow. Like, that
may just become the star and image. We'll
see. I went yeah. I learned I learned
a little bit of grass. I went
figure out how to do an MPEG forward
to a webM. So
Very nice. Alright. Well, thank you both very
much for joining me today, for breaking those
clusters, for powering through and fixing this cluster,
and for running the book club on the
chat along with others, Walid and others as
well. So, you know Yep.
It's very great.
I'm gonna have a very strong drink after
that, Aries. But other than that, have a
wonderful day, everyone. Thank you, Carlos. Thank you,
Eric. Thank you, everyone on the chat. Thank
you, Teleport. Yep. Speak to soon. Thank you.
Bye. Thanks. Bye.